can we help influence choice by
providing the right information at the
right time so we conducted a simple
experiment building on the research of
Brian Wansink and others at Cornell that
indicates that among other things is a
very strong relationship between the
size of the container and how much you
eat so we put out plates so imagine you
walk into one of the cafes that Brian
described and you see all this wonderful
food and you go to grab your plate and
in addition to the standard plate or
used to there's also a small plate we
counted how many plates people chose
which do you choose I will tell you that
most did in fact use a large plate in
seventy-nine percent of fact and you
thought you saw the food it's amazing so
then we describe the research we told
people a bit about this connection we
explained what was going on and then we
count it again and we found that we saw
a fifty percent increase in the choice
of small plates over large plates and a
great deal of satisfaction with having
the option and the most of our people
agreeing that it was very helpful in
controlling their portion size so what's
interesting for me here is is that it's
not always just enough to provide the
nudge but in providing people with
information and giving them the power to
make the decisions and to make them in
an informed way has some substantial
substantial impact that said we also
know that cafes are not the only place
where people eat we have at Google
something we call micro kitchens which
is a terrible misnomer there's nothing
micro about these kitchens it's where
people snack they're great again a
gathering place for folks oh yes what
one of the great things about being an
applied setting is that as i mentioned
we're informing action and so when we
did an experiment the experiment was
done but our work was not and so now
small place is simply a matter of it's
what we do it's a program this is one
example of how those small plates have
continued to roll out at Google alright
so back
micro kitchens this is how we used to
stalk mms yeah used to be like no
they're a couple problems with this now
here's the case I talked previously
about wanting to make choices easier
here's an example where we wanted to
make a choice harder not take it away
but make it something that you did
deliberately right so here the M&M now
it's cereal but it used to be Eminem's
and everything else so this something
that wasn't so healthy for you was given
equal weight and availability of
something that was perhaps the healthier
choice and portion control anyone who's
had the experience of buying bulk food
you realized that you ended up with far
more chocolate covered raisins and you
probably intended so are you going to do
not going to throw them out you probably
end up eating them so similarly so we
redesigned the micro kitchens now you
see the fruit is up front and center is
beautiful there are other options in the
bins but we didn't take the Eminem's
away we just made them a little more
difficult to get to so here they are on
these opaque bins are labeled and what
we found in the seven weeks following
this change Googlers in the New York
office eight 3.1 million fewer calories
from mms by making the portions easier
to control and requiring a more
deliberate choice in the part of
employees